what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to my
reaction series today I am going to be
reacting to the Andrew Tate Vice
documentary so um a little background
I was notified after the show that I
just did that um Andrew Tate released
the video
um basically that he that Vice did a hit
piece on him so now he did a hit piece
back
correct blessing
yeah yeah so and apparently Vice is also
going under
rumored allegedly so let's let's get
this reaction started roll the clip
blessing
yeah all the mainstream media Outlets
which vilify Tate constantly beg for
interviews and appearances under the
guise of balanced journalism The Matrix
is desperate for Tate as it is the only
way
that is the only time anybody cares what
they have to say
foreign
about Vice news remember Vice news
I know they don't learn
I allowed them to come and do a piece on
me in the war room
about seven months ago now
I knew it would be a hit piece of course
I'm a professional but I also knew
anyone with the brain would see through
the hit Peaks to see the beauty of the
worm and want to join so I allowed them
to come do a hit piece
and then
I got interviewed by Piers Morgan I'll
let their calling
it's our friends from Vice but he can
wait
then I interviewed by Piers Morgan and
he came at me hard and all of the
comments are saying bro takes a g
The Matrix tries to tell the world that
everyone hates me but the truth is
everyone actually loves me so when peers
tried to come for me hard expecting to
be a hero he was actually attacked and
he felt like oops I made a mistake which
stopped Vice releasing their hit piece
because they called me and said hey
don't call him
he called me that hey we want to film
some more we feel like we didn't get the
other side of the story basically we
want to undo the hit piece and do the
fair journalism we were supposed to do
in the first place because now we
realize making a hit piece on you
doesn't work out well for us
then I went to jail because I'm Matrix
attacked and I thought ah he's a bad guy
now we can do a hit piece and they
released a hit piece and nobody believed
it just like I said everyone saw through
it salt was garbage to the point where
Vice had to turn the comments off
because everyone was insulting them they
even falsely edited me stuttering when
have you ever seen me stutter on any
video ever to try and make me look
frustrated like I've been caught out by
this dork called Matt
so they released hit peace and it was
totally detrimental for them nobody
believed them Bond their reputation even
worse Vice used to be something and now
they're completely off the deep end
nobody gives a about them complete
Matrix propaganda
so now you're released from jail
and now Matt from Vice is begging me
begging me for another interview
calling me every day Tate come here
we didn't do you like that
you know what I mean the only good
things I just probably think
come sorry sorry I I had to plug I had
to plug this is so entertaining hey
begging me
please please
walk the side because I'm such a nice
man most people have a hit piece done
about them and they don't talk to that
organization anymore but I'm so nice
I'm gonna have a conversation with Vice
news we're gonna talk this man is the
most entertaining man on the planet
ah
we're gonna talk to Matt and messaging
him again I said an instruction
again
like a little dog
so we wait for Matt to call us and we're
gonna hear what Matt has to say about
the fact that they were dishonest
and they weren't particularly good at oh
look
again please Mr
Geeks
well if it isn't math
Andrew hey
Mr honest journalism
yeah that's what that's how I think of
myself
it's a shame nobody else thinks of you
that way Matt that's why you have to
turn off the comments on your little
video
are you at home
where else would he be is he your house
that's just a mean question Matt
that's just a mean question where else
[Laughter]
you know
whatever
congrats on your being released under a
house around
thank you
[Laughter]
[Music]
well
it's a beautiful reality Matt
it's a beautiful life and I'm clearly
one of God's chosen ones
and I'm here to spread a positive
message and continue with my mission
to prevent the degeneracy which is
purported by organizations like Vice
drug taking
and other forms of pornography a bunch
of other stuff you want are involved in
I'm here to combat it and I'm going to
lead people to the truth into the light
and we're all going to be better people
have a better Society for that and I
think you learned that
when you turn the comments off in your
little video that most people understand
I'm a Force for good and that hit pieces
did they turn the car that cuts off on
the video I did for Vice
like the panel thing I need to check I'm
not I'm not you know they do that I did
a four hour video with Vice and they
edited it down it might have been longer
than that they edited it down to like 45
minutes I made some points they edited
it out some point some mic drops
propaganda Channel propaganda Channel I
wish I could react to the vice video but
I think they would copyright me right I
think I tried once and they didn't let
me yeah but this is this is very funny
so funny
funniest man alive
don't really work I don't know because
you've lost all credibility in the
mainstream Matrix mechanisms of the
media
unfortunately for you
I think they were turned off because the
women were getting harassed is that is
that your excuse
although that's what I think is the
reason that they were turned off for but
but anyway regardless I mean look the
main reason of calling is I want to see
whether you were up for doing another
interview not revise but for the BBC
someone just said they won't be able to
copyright uses they're going bankrupt
[Laughter]
should we do it next
should we do it next listen wait until
the fire for bankruptcy we're gonna hit
something yeah yeah yeah so the device
reactions are coming oh we'll react the
hell out of ice
yeah you know they paid for my whole
flight and everything to be honest I
could see why they're going bankrupt I
remember sitting there like thinking how
many producers and they had you
know what I I want to talk about some
things the lady advice was rude to me
all right okay yeah I have an issue with
this advice lady I was asking them oh
can I see your control room could I see
your panel now maybe she's in her right
to say no
oh but you know I bet she needs a job
now
[Laughter]
you know baby had
an opening but I don't know it I know
you know we did have it yeah but it was
like they had so many producers and
now and I kept asking like why they
needed so many people because I was
trying to produce my stuff
I think our looks better than
theirs
I mean
when you got the best producer in the
game shout out to a producers
yeah yeah all right sorry I'm gonna
continue uh Tate pearly flight at Tate's
Place to interview him I would what the
listen whenever they want we're on our
way tomorrow Andrew I'm going to get my
Visa stemmed you know what I mean I mean
I didn't have multiple passports like
you you know I'm from Africa but I'm
gonna get it tomorrow okay do you know
how hard it is for this man to travel I
I couldn't believe it
I want to get my Romanian Visa today I'm
coming
um that interview is happening to you
I'm manifested
ah why would you want to interview me
I'm a bad person I call according to
your little uh story
[Music]
that's at every story so oh you do both
sides is that how you think you were
well that includes your side as well so
you know it was obviously difficult to
interview you while you were uh in jail
now you're out you know we can actually
have a chance to hear your side of
things
problem is Matt
everyone on the planet wants to
interview me
so the question is why would I choose
you when I have unlimited offers from
people who are far more successful and
better than you at the job
because I'd be doing and I'm not trying
to disrespect you I'll be honest I'd be
doing you a favor like math we'll take
the favor we'll take it
yeah
yeah I know you probably got better
offers I won't lie to you I I like I
can't even like I can't even you know
help a brother out
you know you're not sorry from the ends
you know
what's your last name Shane
that name didn't matter until it was
Associated to mine you do an interview
with me you matter for a little bit but
I can do an interview with anyone
so why would I do an interview with you
and this isn't genuinely a question it's
not an insult I'm actually asking you
why I would choose you when I have
unlimited offers on the table
because we have a history
[Laughter]
sounds like a ex-girlfriend we had a
history yeah I know that I was the guy
because it is
okay I'll tell you we got the best
production on YouTube
we have a history tape yeah we
yeah we got one yeah history
[Laughter]
we got clementines here
we'll bring clementines
do you want something right now could
you could you give me one
look at this costume yeah
I mean the history of you doing
dishonest journalism on me so I would
choose you interesting
any journalist that you speak to is
going to
ask you the similar questions the ones I
asked you I have no problem with your
questions
the reason the reason that I want to do
an interview with you and of course you
can do an interview with anyone you want
and
see this clementines this is what this
is the customer service you get at just
for early things you can call us big
time
many people asking you I guess but we
have a history and we got cut short last
time and there are still unanswered
questions that I want to put to you I
can only tell you why I want to
interview you you know ultimately it is
your choice
it is my choice isn't it I get to choose
which reporter in the world all these
reporters who want to say bad things
about me I get to choose which report
are on the planet gets to become
relevant via proxy because I am the most
relevant person and I get to do the
charitable Act of allowing somebody to
sit next to me and ask me questions
it's kind of interesting I need to think
heavily about it I can't just give out
such a fantastic opportunity to
disingenuous nobodies it's something I
need to think about do you work for the
BBC now or do you work for yourself
I'm an independent contractor but it has
to be broadcast somewhere and I think
the BBC is is where it would go
but one thing I would say though is
uh I spoke to the sartorial shooter and
he said that one of the things you might
want is the chance to film it and record
it yourself
Oh you mean so you can edit in stutters
like you did with Vice to pretend I was
stuttering when I was answering
questions is that what is that why
yes you do Matt the algorithm to make
you become more famous and more viral
I'm not an expert on algorithms for
social media platforms I do not have
most of them installed on my phone I
cannot control a 15 year old Singaporean
decides to do when he chops me up and
calls me names I can't control that and
I wouldn't try to when you search for
Europe I wouldn't try to when you search
you did add it in a stutter dude what
should my guys should I should I send a
message to Tate
please do yeah yeah okay I'll send him a
I'll send him a text you know
what should it be
what should it we have a history
[Laughter]
did I is that some of my opener should
be oh yeah the history laughing emoji
hello did I say we have a history
we have
oh that guy's buddy we yeah you know
you know
yeah
let's let's
we have a history I should just say that
is that what we're going with it still
hey pull up tape do you want us to pull
up yeah you know you want us to pull up
with uh man we can be there okay yeah
let us let us know you know
[Music]
looking for an opportunity
foreign
one of the associated terms why then of
the Romanian police said the
investigation is ongoing I'm not sure
where you got that information from I'm
not sure who said it is there some kind
of procedure that must be completed I
don't know there has been a lot of bad
sure that must be completed I don't know
there has been a lot of bad
the eclipse channels are evil
yeah I've been beefing on Twitter today
what's happening
yeah so I've been beefing destiny
what did he do now now because he just
argues like nothing all the time and so
I'm just tired of these clips channels
they don't believe in anything they
don't stand for anything they have no
more they have no cause all right
and it would be one thing you know
there's some people that have channels
and they're like impartial observers
okay
so they just they just say what it is
like these are the facts and they don't
give their opinion but the reaction
channels they give their opinion that's
just to argue with you there's no real
point get divorced over chores
divorce is hard for women because they
age
like these are the these are the
arguments and so this is what what is
there this is the same thing it's
Eclipse channel the documentary it's not
fair journalism it's just it's just it's
a hit piece it's Tate is a bad guy
now look guys I don't have an extensive
history with Taylor let's just call
spade a spade right
I met the man once
I see them online
but I'm
a bit reluctant to make a full hip piece
on someone
you gotta
you gotta have a reason especially if
they were really nice when they came
here yeah he was so nice when he came
you know polite guy
polite to the vice reporter but does he
care
no because they have a narrative they
want to spin and this is what you'll
find out
reaction channels
will have a view on you already
they'll already have a view now one
certain reaction channel to me even
admitted that yeah they said they didn't
like me the first message and that's
what this reaction channel did to him he
already didn't like him so he comes
there for in the name of fair journalism
does he do Fair journalism no no
I can tell you I've experienced this
firsthand where reaction channels paint
a narrative
clip you up they clip you up and paint a
narrative
I can't control that and I wouldn't try
to when you search for you're sure that
must be completed I don't know there has
been a lot of bad
let's be honest with each other we have
a history we're friends now don't lie
Stoppers were edited in to try and make
it look like you stumped me with your
asinine questions which of course is
absolutely impossible
[Laughter]
what you might be referring to is
sometimes we cut to b-roll of someone's
face when we're editing an interview
because you know we spoke for almost an
hour but it gets cut down to only a few
minutes so there are going to be some
edits and we already need to cut to your
face at some point
um you dishonestly edited okay we agree
yeah that's what they do
that's what they do
because they're a bunch of dorks they
just sit they just sit in their little
on their phones
and in their rooms I'm not gonna name
names
in a squeaky Studio a squeaky studio and
they just sit there and they're critics
they're the TMZ of YouTube the TMZ of
the news this is guys the T you Vice is
going out of business yeah BuzzFeed is
going out of business where do they go
to
they have no real talent they can't make
any original content they can't push the
conversation forward and they never have
a point
where so where are they going to go the
reaction channels on YouTube
we edit I would say we don't dishonestly
edit it but the idea that we would just
release a you know an hour long unedited
entity it doesn't really make sense
right because it's all documentaries
only 45 minutes so and anyway but the
point is I can't stop you filming in
your own home you know really I'm not
stoned guys stop putting that in the
chat
all right you know it's a it's a late
night blessing asked me to do this
reaction after the show stop stop saying
that I'm stoned in the chat and Mr T
just released a very funny video we have
to do right now you know we don't do
drugs no drugs no drugs don't do drugs
no alcohol none of that none of that
are you saying whatever you want to
release editing it however you want to
edit it you know I can't stop you doing
that so if that's what you want to do
then you obviously can do it and then
you know when people say
oh not you've unfairly edited this or
whatever you can say well here's the the
full unedited you're right version
you're right I can film our interview to
protect myself from your dishonest
journalism I appreciate that thank you
laughs
oh he's so funny I'm gonna think about
it Matt because I'm the one who matters
here I can sit down with Peter
with
Big Bird Oscar the Grouch I can sit down
with anybody that'll be the most viewed
podcast or interview in the world so I'm
gonna think about it that's true would
you would you bring me a box of
chocolates
I can bring you a box of chocolates
if you promise to bring me a box of
chocolates that will increase your
chances
oh he's so funny
answer within 24 hours but you have to
promise me Matt don't lie to me
but let's add that in the chat guys
we'll craft a text as a group
so one we have a history we're gonna
bring a box of chocolates no and
Clementine clementines clementines yeah
let's let's get this pitch together with
my superiors whether I can send you a
box yeah take the notes blessing so I
don't forget yeah I want people to teach
you some ideas as well yeah yeah put
some put some ideas in here yeah
chocolates well then you check with your
boss you go into your boss's room and
ask if you're allowed to spend
a large portion of your salary on a five
pound box of chocolates and you let me
know and if you can then I will strongly
consider allowing you
the opportunity
we'll do it where how much chocolate we
gotta bring we'll do it we'll do it
speak with me
are you asking all the journalists to
bring you a box of chocolates no I'm not
high as a kite stop saying that in the
chat I don't smoke
have you ever seen me indulge in weed
I don't I don't do stop putting that
sorry guys I'm not trying to make this
about me but it's offensive it's
offensive
I'm not stoned I'm just tired
one if you think it was thrown into the
chat no no stop it yes put one in the
chat oh my God stop
give Pearl AC for the summer thank you
we'd like please give us this interview
we don't have enough money for AC
[Music]
um
foreign
oh my gosh sleep deprivation is her drug
that's true that's a fact
them the ones that going in there that's
so rude anyone was putting to his part
device
why are you encouraging this where are
you okay well see we gotta Focus we're
trying to we're trying to watch the
video yeah if you're trying to watch the
video
it'd be agrees the chocolates I'll agree
to the interview
what we're gonna do is record him
standing around waiting for interview
with my box chocolates
stop
[Music]
[Laughter]
you see this is the world beautiful Vice
do a hit piece on tape Tate Goes to Jail
we got him release the hit piece he's in
jail he's never getting out God releases
me Vice map BBC whoever Matrix agent
number 399 begs for another interview
and I end up with chocolates
it's kind of like
I never lose
a few moments later
hello Max
um I can bring you a box of chocolates
that's great
here we are see I went to jail everyone
said tape's over his life's done he's
gonna go to jail turns out I was totally
innocent I've been let free and now I
get chocolates from Vice
quite freaking good
from the BBC oh even for the BBC's even
better they've got bigger budgets don't
let don't let me down man
don't be cheap
so when works for you
how soon can you get the chocolates
as soon as you want I'm pretty hungry
um
assuming the chocolates are procured
this man's the world's biggest troll
what day is it today Tuesday
[Music]
yeah
um yeah Friday Saturday something like
that assuming the chocolates are ready
but it depends who you're gonna come
with because I need to talk to my lawyer
on house arrest blah blah
all right so what could we pitch them so
chocolates Clementine
we have a history yeah
and pills gonna smoke a cigar
a cigar yeah
no I don't want to do that you don't no
it's like it's that's their thing you
know they don't want women doing that
women aren't meant to smoke cigars
[Music]
put a one in the chat if I should offer
the cigar
oh no who will bring some glass I will
bring yeah we'll bring yeah bring some
cigars
Friday works uh if I need to get
permission to visit you from the police
I'm sure I can do that I can probably do
that how then my lawyer can handle all
that how many of you are coming
it would just be
it would just be three people no me
okay let me talk to my lawyer and I'll
get back to you
hopefully
gotcha
oh that is so that is
why are there brokeys in the chat Sun
supers you know what I mean they're I'm
tired of people saying I have a broke
audience just so you know at Pearl can
you comment on the whole role chat ggb
has with Fox News CNN BuzzFeed advice
all either changing businesses or going
out of business
is that because of chat GTB
I don't know
yeah
bring him to coffees one for him to
drink and one to look at
yeah look it will okay guys you need to
Super Chat how are you gonna afford all
these things yeah yeah we got it we
gotta we gotta send super I need someone
you know with a 20 or something yeah
it's like we got three kids three k
people in here
hey this is embarrassing you guys are
tit fins yeah the brokies
yeah yeah
put a one in the chat if you're broke
several days later
um
yeah Matt this is Matt and he looks in
the BBC all right I'm gonna let you
actually win okay what
[Laughter]
be right back okay
good morning
breakfast yeah I love breakfast it's
about very important interview today
what did you tell me the broke his life
wait what wow I guess my audience
is broke God damn
[Music]
don't ask me don't ask me your blessing
because we spend money like it's water
you know what I mean yeah like we just
buy we just we just oh he's not a bro
thank you John yeah me and me and
blessing just we just swipe that credit
card you know Nicole Nicholas king
that's so sweet of you thank you
Nicholas thank you Nicholas King you
know two two people are rich you know
the rest are broken you know you know at
least we have two you know
oh another
average guys like me thank you I I
assumed so too until I saw this chat
a lot of yeah a lot of rookies yeah yeah
you know but it's all right all right
we're gonna continue we'll continue
a dollar it's a month okay I'm sorry but
at a dollar you might as well not send
anything
hey that's all you can afford you know I
mean he knows his level it's okay you
know oh they gifted five memberships
thank you Jerome guess we have no war
remembers in here yeah you know they
can't affair they can't afford the war
room so they come to Pearl's chat
you know yo take come man you know like
you know you see some more room content
yeah you know you know we'll sponsor the
boxing match too
are very important interview today with
a various uh renowned esteemed
well-known journalists you know Matt
Shea yeah as you can see I'm dressed for
the occasion
[Applause]
here he is
up please come on we got a broken but
broke not broke it broken but trying
thank you Chad is spending all the money
on weed and hahaha thank you super chats
I'm gonna let the video play for a
second though so I'm gonna try to
screenshot these so I see them we need
the security system like tastes like
this is yeah we need to we don't even
have a kick out cam yeah
yeah
you know I think that I think the
conclusion is that we are in fact the
brokies yeah indeed help us out
another interview
please okay
gee what a dork imagine being imagine
going to school as a kid okay and
everyone's like you're a geek you're a
nerd okay you're a dork and then you
grow up
and they were right
[Laughter]
that's not Shay's reality all right
what's one of his interviews about the
drug in Colombia and he was sniffing
cocaine in the interview as I said
they're doing a left reaction ways away
you go inside
mad
about how the drug people aren't
actually that bad
it's cocaine people
but then he does hit pieces on good
people
he is a dork a nerd and a geek dng he's
dng dng I haven't heard of it I've seen
a dng in person and you know what's
amazing well
his stupid ass didn't do what me and you
would have done jump on a Jack and fly
somewhere no he went to the airport
checked in with their economy hey hey we
gotta travel somehow all right let's not
let's not you know
I'm manifesting I'm gonna be on a jet
with tech one day
plus and this is getting sad at this
point you gotta a manifest in there I
don't believe in the word manifesting
Ah that's a discussion for another day
it's another day all right all right all
these bags on the thing through
the security went through all that
at 4am this morning to come here and
stand outside my house like a dick
is
annual salary this cost
well
what do you call it I know I'm having my
breakfast
so he has to wait it's called me
he certainly will still there
did he have chocolate
sorry why is he here to do anything
about
the most famous man in the world the
most influential man in the world the
world who owns the culture the person
who's gonna say planet Earth me
of course I decided to chew an interview
with him to boost his career because he
was so honest last time I gave him a
chance
advice episode 2. I actually did but
this time
[Applause]
[Laughter]
it's a straight Savage do you think he's
gonna go out at all
yeah I'll do the same thing as well
after you make a heap his
yeah yeah I just want you everyone to
know that I have taken names
of everybody that's done hit pieces on
me we've taken names
yeah
and some of you guys's channels are not
doing well right now some of y'all
aren't doing well
and we got a video coming
yeah you know what I'm really excited to
give my side of the story
for that whole thing if you know you
know I'm really excited
to give my side of all these people
doing dishonest journalism
being us clipping us making us look mad
but it's okay it's okay we're very
compassionate people yeah
I mean you got to get paid somehow you
know but it's been sad but well
anyways yeah
it's gonna be great
dng this is an energy man
that's not the end if you can't stand
this is my area this is all I have to
say to him
[Laughter]
thank you
so I spoke with Andrew he said he's
tired right now okay and like to give
him his jacket
give him his chocolate yep okay we can
give it to him once we're sat down to do
the interview
this has to be the most someone has ever
spent for a delivery
chocolates
they paid all them flight tickets to
deliver chocolates I'm telling you it's
not gonna come out
you know what's crazy you know what's
crazy
what oh there's one one person I'm
shouting like in the chat you know loyal
guide who this guy called Brighton oh oh
thank you Brighton yeah
you know what's crazy it's crazy how
it's gonna feel like the victim after
all of this
but really you deserve this you had this
coming I'm really excited to watch this
just like that just yeah just like
there's certain people that may feel
like they're victims at a certain video
we have coming out soon but you know
what
I don't want to hear anything
yeah
[Laughter]
oh red pill Bachelor coming awesome yeah
there's a
um there's a red pill Bachelor so we are
in fact releasing
um support content creators here at just
pearly things we will be releasing all
footage from any red pill Bachelor that
has been shot I won't name names but any
um you know request to not post it it's
very inconsiderate to um all of the
other content creators involved my staff
that they cared so much about oh as a
genius piece of work right there you
know that blessing is still waiting to
hear back from aren't you all the people
that were so concerned about you you're
still waiting I want my chocolates
yeah he's so sad and he also um it's
crazy it's such a horrible work
environment that you with these horrible
contracts that you went in accepted all
the job offers you were offered right
listen
I want my chocolates
conditions yeah quite amazing but I want
my chocolates yeah yeah yeah so um as an
apology those content creators
feel free to send chocolate you know
what I mean yeah chocolates yeah
yeah but you know we won't Name It We
Don't name names here no no we'll be
mine in that video anyways um stay tuned
coming up soon coming up soon
very very soon now he wants the
chocolate now yeah okay because I'm a
little bit worried that he's just gonna
you know brag about us bringing him
chocolate on Twitter and not actually do
the interview
Okay so
is he too afraid to come out and say it
himself uh no he's just tired he's
having his breakfast now okay could you
do me a favor could you ask him if he is
scared of doing an interview thank you
Stacy Campbell okay sure thank you yep
so he asked you if you are scared to go
out and talk to him
every time now he said I'm scared I
really have to go I can't just smoke my
cigar and ignore him
where's my chocolate you're definitely
going to be more upset I get called
scared than him wasting his entire week
correct he didn't want to give you the
chocolate now she wants to get in this
house what is there's a guy called ill
courses we need to get more Specialists
on the panel
Fitness all of that and we're working on
it now we are we are
well you can wait a while let's give
them about 10 minutes
I think he's beginning to realize the
reality of this interview
and I was like why are you so obsessed
with me
[Laughter]
hey
Loki likes Mariah Carey like look he's
been playing a lot
yeah she's a Vibe still
obsessed with me
I like a little shimmy you know what I
mean
today I can't think of anything I'm
supposed to do
I mean Mario my safest man in the world
okay
already on the culture we're fighting
back against the Matrix I already know
on keto I understand so do my keto so
quickly that it creates a vortex
tornado goes High into the sky
um
today so there's nothing to do
with the dng outside
it's been 45 minutes now
[Laughter]
whoa he flew a comedy G it was time with
his bags putting them in the overhead
sorry bumping into people
[Laughter]
sorry for all my bags I'm going to pour
an interview on the report okay
you look like a geek you're outside my
door looking like a geek
fake news video
they're still there he is fake news
what are we gonna afford a taxi home
baby stuff there I wonder what crappy
Hotel he's staying in it's not saying a
good one is it
all right let's not on crappy
hotels because that is exactly what me
and blessing will be staying in when we
go to the US next week
you know my first time in the US and I
don't know what pill has planned for me
but be careful me please Super Chat yeah
I don't know yo you know money's Money's
been tight since the entire internet
made a million hit pieces on us you know
you know you know you know that was that
was not a good month for us not a great
month you know
I'm so glad they cared
I really would encourage you know what
to all the reaction channels like heard
so much about blessing any Super Chat
that you send
um specifically from those reaction
channels that said they cared about him
is the soup any super chats now they'll
go towards blessing oh yeah yeah no just
from those reaction channels let's not
get carried away
you know you they know who they are
you could you can name the names if you
want then listen I don't care about
those people yeah they're not sending
nothing huh
well let's anyways
must realize what's happened
I think he now must realize that he's
been checkmated
in the grand Game of Life
performing Marina take the trash out I
guess that's the story of advice work
order
they're filming Marina our housekeeper
take the trash out
I guess that's his advice story now
you are mad that's such an owl
no this is Justice this is funny pal
this is Justice right there Tay that's a
win keep doing that that's that's a win
right there
misogynistic influencer Andrew Tate has
garbage which he uses to litter the
landfills and damage the ozone layer
because of global warming
matisha
[Laughter]
[Music]
nerd
two bags of rubbish from his house that
contained micro Plastics get a life you
games they want micro plastic
shut the up he likes making garbage
documentaries isn't it
nerd you could film just the bag
of garbage for the entire documentary
and it'd still be less garbage than the
last one we tried to make
they're still there
I'll have some pride back come on just
off man did he get the chocolates
or no
I'm waiting for it yeah
come on man that's the kind of guy get
in your head that's kind of guy who will
arrange to meet your girl for dinner
show up at the restaurant with his eight
pound 64 in his pocket ready to drive
silver a good time her not show up and
then sit at the table for five hours
well maybe you'll talk to me looks that
kind of guy he is but clearly
you know the worst thing I don't feel
sorry for him one percent
neither should anyone else
these are the worst type of people
they're literally ages of the Matrix
ages of Mentor they will edit your
speech and cut your sentences up to make
it look like you said something
different they will misrepresent you the
Matrix in the most callous and grotesque
and most promiscuous and absorbative
manner reaction channels and media
companies like Vice stand for nothing
believe nothing and really have no real
thought or ideology you don't know what
they believe and they usually just bring
you to destruction
facts they don't care about you
facts they don't want you to win
and they're really just critics in the
TMZ of YouTube
yeah
yeah yeah don't support those people
guys that's met
and now he thinks that he's gonna come
here and walk interview you again
the dng
Body Energy
the original the game quite dancing we
need to get that training
Matthew
it's good thanks
um
I thought I sent someone out to say come
back a bit later I just woke up
uh what time is it now
2 2 30. yeah
see you then perfect ah Matt do you have
my chocolate
yes I brought you chocolate good because
there's no access to the house without
chocolate at 2 30. I want you to know
that
no no you don't make the rules around
here young man you will give me my
chocolate before you come into my house
at 2 30 when we do our interview
whoa
[Laughter]
man
he's making a house arrest look lit
right there yeah what
yo
feed this man man yeah free the man free
free Tate
[Laughter]
[Applause]
oh
you look like a geese
right all right now let's see what they
do let's film them before they get a
taxi
I'm standing outside the house of
millionaire Andrew too tell me to come
back later and my wheels
you have things attraction in the back
stretch of microblastics
[Music]
you look like a gay bro
copyright
oh sorry guys oh yeah blessings
blessings helping us out
all right tick tocks still housing toxic
posts a band influencer Andrew Tate okay
yeah
it looks like something I'm gonna have
to do with my personal training yeah
blessing actually went to training today
we're proud of him put a one in the chat
if you're proud of your blessing for
training today all because of
we'll give this to Tate's motivation
Tate blessing blessings I said I want to
get fit yeah temptate comes out you know
yes to make sense
no one has deserved for this more than
him ever massage my head please because
I've got there's a dng outside and it's
it's his negative energy you know what I
mean it's just
oh
affecting your brain power on it it's
like I'm so cool but when a nerd is
outside begging at the gate
[Music]
like his patheticness and his Insidious
weakness is in the atmosphere and I have
to make sure that I found my chi so I
got breathe smoking stop breathing smoke
massage my hero super brain to purify my
existence because there's some dng in my
gate Who Won't Give Up
please
you look
like a geek
get I finished my lunch
but it's my 15th coffee of the day and
continue to conquer the world and be
rich
good point some dng don't end up like a
dng standing outside a man's gate
We're Not Gonna Miss You just giving him
massage
[Laughter]
to use the different left I respect it
fine who's there calling me to stand
outside of man's gay your only big shot
in the world to ever be noticed again
you look is that guy's come out like a
key and there is less than zero percent
chance the worst thing is I said come
back at 2 30 and he arrived on time to
the minute
okay
Mr punctual maybe if I get there exactly
on time we'll let me in
foreign
[Music]
you know we're punctual people I'm just
gonna throw this in there you know
well
blessing stop it don't don't wow all
right you know I'm a mean yeah I don't
you know saying you pal you know I'm a
punctual person yeah yeah when the
African time
oh
he is on
um
uh
an amazing producer what did they think
I was gonna say
I don't know but I'm on the African time
[Music]
will not let them poison me
I refuse if my Life Commission never end
up anything like that man yeah my life's
ambition never be anything like him I
and a little worm who comes along and
does hit pieces on people who are trying
to pretend to be their friends try and
get hits on the internet and everyone
realizes he's a little worm and they're
so desperate to matter that he has to
beg the same person he betrayed for
attention again because he is a complete
who would ever talk to him that's
relevant now so I mean you're not
talking to him
talk to who
the dng
what makes a about him
I have an interview no
you look like a king we didn't fly here
and I'll consider it
[Laughter]
oh
who's calling me
you're busy I'm super busy I'm working
repelling is negative organs
nerd
foreign
do you have the chocolate yeah okay can
I have the chocolate so I can look
obviously what we don't want is to give
you the chocolate not to the interview
right no
[Laughter]
yeah
it's a win for the editor
so but I know you want to film us giving
you the job I know what superchat they
want us to read here but everybody's
been going on about this Super Chat what
they're talking about
what can you I I lost them on my phone
yeah we're gonna read the supercharge
stick it out guys you know yeah one
second we're gonna read them yeah drop
the chocolate just pull the super chats
up there you're gonna be a Super Chat
reader
oh okay
hope you're better than this
Super Chat right he was so bad they
ain't on mine so if you or Tate can
cover the way where we're both happy
then you're not gonna get an interview
without the chocolate yeah you know
that's fine so how about uh if you tell
Tay he can come out and then we can hand
him the chocolate as we enter and you
can film it
okay I'm gonna tell him but he's pretty
busy
what is the cameraman for me the focus
yeah why is why do you have your eye on
the thing like it's 20 23 like why did
you bring that big thing what's going on
there man
Vice BBC what's going on over there man
I mean they clearly don't have a good
budget like we do I just probably thinks
yeah I mean yeah like let's get iPhone
at this point you know I mean you guys
I know what they do I don't know
we twerk oh really
okay so he wants you to go out and get
the chocolate because he's scared he's
not gonna get an interview if he's gonna
give you the chocolate why didn't you
say you will get interviewed once you
get in trouble I told him and what did
you saying he wants you to go outside
and he can like
laughs
[Music]
foreign
oh my God this is so funny
read the super chats now you got them up
you know how to pull them up yeah
and uh you either give him the chocolate
and you'll have an interview or you
don't and you don't have to give you
okay so yeah
where is the chocolate where's he he's
inside okay cool well yeah you have to
give him the chocolate first okay if he
comes out we'll give it to him he he
won't come out
if you give me the chocolate I'll get
the chocolate to him and you'll have an
interview your name's steak right what's
your name
okay right so you're obviously a smart
person
you know that if I give you obviously
not
[Laughter]
you're not met
and the chocolate and take the L at this
point
then there's a high chance he'll never
come out right but at least it's a
chance if you don't give it give him the
chocolate you won't have an interview
yes but I'm I'm not gonna give him the
chocolate
and then just risk him not appearing so
what I could do I don't understand
you've already made it all the way to
Romania like you like if
you chocolate like just take the L you
know
why is he trying to keep like a ransom
with the chocolate like it was
a chocolate gate
okay okay
I I need to know I need to know if he
gets the chocolate I need to know
let's find out his hand in the chocolate
as we walk in that's a smart idea right
nope
because he he doesn't want that he wants
the chocolate he's gonna do an interview
with you what do you think about all
this
um I'm outside now you don't have any
thoughts yeah no what are you doing you
can't think
a bit rude you're gonna you know they
say a person's true character is how
they treat the waiter now this isn't a
waiter but it's the same principles they
help get the help yeah like I take it
personal if someone is rude there was a
girl that wanted that came on the show
okay
but the Sadia chick all right I'm gonna
say her name
and this is this pro-men influencers
came on my show yeah and then after
proceeds to call one of my staff
a broke man wow and and degrade one of
the people that worked for me and then
asked to come back on the show lady you
will never never because I don't like
influencers that degrade men
I think that's absolutely atrocious
and so now you see and now now what did
that show us that showed her true
character
and what are we seeing here sometimes
the people that are nice
are not nice
they're weak
and this is his true character the way
he treats an innocent bystander in all
of this
an innocent bystander it's not that it's
just I don't want to get involved in
this but you are involved you're
literally filming me yeah that's it you
know okay
yeah so what do you do for undertake you
work from full time or again he's just
uh you have to give me the chocolate or
if not
yeah how does it work no
so what so this is the last time I'm
gonna come out yeah so yeah you're
either gonna give me the chocolate I'm
gonna give him the chocolate you'll have
an interview if not this is getting
quite silly though
[Music]
oh my God this is the funniest thing
ever
we gotta tell our Clippers to do this
this is too good
isn't it I mean
is he gonna do an interview with us even
if we gave him the chocolate
maybe maybe
there is a bigger chance he's gonna do
an interview with you if you bring him
the chocolate I'll call him
[Music]
why does he think he can go over some
you see this is my problem with people
sometimes they think they can get to the
top without going through the stairs you
know I mean climb up the stairs this guy
at the gate is your way in if he was
nice to him maybe he would have actually
got the interview no maybe from around
here
he was gonna get it but my thing is I
just don't like when people treat people
poorly when they're doing a job
yeah it would be one thing if the
security guard was rude to him in any
way but he wasn't rude you just said
give me the chocolate and I mean just
you came with the chocolate why is it
gonna go back with it
it's a bit you know it's not genuine now
I'm thinking maybe that's why if they if
he had that chocolate and had the skin
Rush thing
that chocolate now is I'm raising
suspicion on that chocolate if he gave
that chocolate oh he got the chocolate
maybe that's what I take got sick the
other day hmm that would be it there
what do you think do you think he got
the chocolate
we're gonna bet
you wanna bet
I think he's gonna give the chocolate
yeah like give the chocolate yeah he
doesn't I think the same thing he just
doesn't he doesn't give me like strong
man energy yeah
yeah
yeah it's an element
[Music]
why why did you think Tay was gonna pick
up his phone call like it's just it's
actually stupid he's actually just a
stupid guy at this point yeah not the
sharpest sharper still yeah how did he
get a job I think they're just hiring
everyone in advice in it
yeah they should be asking me for jobs
I'm like hard yeah do you know what's
crazy advice they looked at me like I
was just
some stupid chick you know I could just
feel it
listen they all they all call me dumb
guys but they're all unemployed now baby
good luck if if five people are like
this then I don't wanna I Don't Wanna
Live Here Yeah
[Music]
okay since he's not picking up hi Andrew
uh look so I know you want to film you
want to film us giving you the chocolate
so
um I you know I'm happy for you to do
that I just as I'm sure you know like I
don't want to risk a situation where I
give you the chocolate and then uh we
don't get in so why don't we do
something like you come out and you know
we speak face to face and I give you the
chocolate as we walk in
[Music]
there so I need payment in advance
unfortunately
well look can you suggest a way in which
we can uh find you know feel some sort
of assurance that you're gonna speak to
us like maybe if you come out now and we
can hand it to you face to face
[Music]
so this time you must trust me that's
the circle of life
must place your faith in the top G and
hand over the chocolate the payment for
his presence
unprecedented access to my private
Network and Home in which you were a bad
faith actor if you still are scared
about losing your heavy Financial
investment of six pounds in a box of
chocolates then you will not get your
interview well it's a hard line the
thing is
you know I'm a journalist
you can't just
yeah yeah
I should have just left the chocolates
you know I mean
all right well he get
I still think he's gonna get the
chocolate if he gets the chocolates um I
am starting the conspiracy theory the
advice tried to poison and retake I
don't care
you know you can't just assume that it's
midnight
imagine a world in which just cause
someone let you into their house they
didn't report on the truth about you I
mean that would be insane
the the problem is it's becoming quite
obvious that you're afraid no
no no he didn't get the chocolate no
he's pretending like he's talking to
Tate he hung up the phone call
he's talking to himself right now
oh no I'm still waiting to the end of
the day I think he gave it up
[Music]
thank you
you are one pathetic loser
[Music]
okay how about um
one square of chocolate
um
[Music]
why is he acting like he has any
leverage here this man is rich
that's a funny thing would would take
came we were trying to think of stuff to
like get him you know and it was like
what do you get someone
who has everything it's like
yeah we got it Clementine
you know
yeah but he's a chess player respect
this game you know imagine like someone
doing a hippies and you wait all this
time and then you bring him and you put
him on this well stage I mean 4 700
people right now yeah Justin on our
channel it's probably gonna go on to do
I don't know how many people
imagine if many people did hit pieces on
you
and you just waited and you waited and
you just waited
that day fell and you just one day
dropped a video
yeah it's a lot of pertinent information
in it
huh
[Music]
yeah but you know who would do that
let's watch the video
you said just give you chocolate right
so if I give if you give you a square of
chocolate no
okay see you
one hour later
yes Matt
hi Andrew
um yes so I've just been interviewing
your fans outside
um they all have been saying very nice
things about you
one guy who you helped get over his weed
addiction another guy who's come all the
way from Miami
um I'm a nice guy Matt you didn't know
well
look you know there's it frustrating
that I can't give you these chocolates
because I literally have no choice in
the matter
it seems you put bad
faith in me
chocolate first give to Alex then you
can come in thank you for your time
think about it I'm home all day
that's how you saved him low
don't worry if I like to send my boss
it's actually
not this at all it's simply that my boss
won't let me
I've used that excuse before
well your boss won't let you drop a
chocolate no not for chocolate but look
at guys
oh no management didn't approve it I'm
My Own management
if you said something like management
didn't approve it to get out of
something and someone made a hit piece
on you
um
saying management doesn't let her do
things
the amount of misinformation you know
that would be great sorry sorry sorry
sorry it'll be very funny that'd be very
funny very very funny that would be very
very funny but you know sorry okay but
yeah I've used that before though so you
know it's not gonna It's Not Gonna Fly
With Me
I'm Bound by the policies of the company
I'm contracted to cat sadly that may
mean we have to leave but it does seem
silly because you obviously have
important things to say and this is for
the BBC it would be a huge platform to
get your message across I'm outside
interviewing your your fans right now
why is he acting like Tate needs the BBC
now
bruh it's the internet days bro hey yeah
BBC you see it if only there was a great
YouTube channel that would come to you
you know you know
in London
nearby yeah just one one flight away we
have a history yeah
yeah
way that you can think of where
I can come in and hand them to you as I
walk in or anything then that would be
great otherwise
I don't know
otherwise what Matt what happens
maybe just you'll have to let me know
when
maybe your next free or something
do I miss out on the opportunity of a
lifetime
you posted in the right time
you know
well Mr Tate
well my name is Blessing and you know
I'm just making a plea though we'll give
the chocolate first in good faith you
know what I mean don't worry we'll send
multiple chocolate boxes your way you
know you just won't be one yeah it'll be
like five actually we're just gonna send
one anyways yeah let's just do that yeah
yeah
no I mean you'll probably be able to get
an interview with other media Outlets
I'm sure but I do think the BBC is a
really big and important platform and I
think that
uh probably
definitely definitely that's right let's
be professional Let's Be Clever with our
language here let's be on point I can
definitely get another interview
and I can get another interview with the
BBC I can just say send someone else
they'll do anything I want
[Music]
wait did you just say that this guy is
over exaggerated these relevancy we
don't know who you are we have no idea
yeah we I got no idea who this Matt
character is don't care I found it I
found out today his name was Matt
yeah we didn't even care from the vice
documentary we didn't even care we care
about Vice
I know you yeah
that's the thing these journalists
reaction channels they get these big
egos like they're doing something goes
over their heads yeah when they really
have no original content no new ideas
nothing interesting to say said sad yeah
yeah no you can I can you can honestly
if you go to them they will they will
say well you're telling me me Andrew
Tate the most famous man in the world
can't get an interview with the BBC
unless you're involved is that the level
of hubris you operate
I'm here so okay look the other thing is
because of our the fact that we have
this sort of For Better or Worse
reputation where somehow you know we've
become sort of Internet menaces
um even though that's not how I see it
then
um
it probably would be
reach a much wider audience and be
viewed and talk about a lot more and
that's just the brass tax of it is what
I think so you know if
there's any if there's any way if you
want to do like a quick one through the
gate like I think that would be great
but it's
it's yeah my hands are tied Read The
Chocolate situation but I don't know if
you have any suggestions no I don't want
to do a quick interview I want to do an
in-depth detailed interview my first
interview under house arrest is going to
be world breaking it's going to be
massive perhaps the biggest
internet interview of the Year perhaps
of the decade
I own the culture and I want to do it
properly but I can't
this can happen or you just barely
things we see
you know ah blessing this is starting to
look desperate I am desperate
listen hell
peaches from more desperate the BBC is
desperate it I'm saying yeah I just
barely fixed their way
yeah okay we know where we know our
place
it will be doing us a very big favor
like you did in December with our
history Mr Tay if you come if you come
out you come you're going to come out
I'll build a new set just for you sir
you can't why are you rubbing it in
blessing he can't come out no he's gonna
come on soon then faith is going to come
up but nobody's that house or no if not
if he doesn't interview outside you know
when he comes out from the house oh okay
okay okay yeah I'm gonna build a new set
for him yeah yeah uh pill is gonna find
it anyway
I'll find it you guys super chop
got the energy which will be procured
from chocolate
and then I'll feel confident Within
Myself to get the energy required to
deal with the fake news media
but then when I come in the door from
that point there I'm pretty sure that I
can just give them to you so then you
will have them that's a that's I'm I'm
still bowing down to your demand there
that's uh I think that's a pretty good
I'm I'm a fair man Matt unlike you I do
not do snakery I do not do tricks in
games I do not pretend to be someone I'm
not we're very different people I have
given you a very fair and simple a very
fair and simple parameter you can decide
if you want to comply or if you want to
fly home again I'm sure that they flew
you on a private jet they flew you on a
Jet right
you said that you didn't care if it was
a hickeys or whatever I'm not I all I
said was I was doing an objective
documentary the whole time and I want
you to give you the chance to give your
side of the story that's why oh you're
giving me a chance you're such a nice
guy
thanks these accusations are coming out
regardless what accusations what the
same girls from 10 years ago got
disproved do you think anyone cares
about that please Matthew you're not
giving me a chance I'm giving you a
chance I'm giving you a very fair
parameter it's a parameter that you can
either adhere to or you can go home and
fly home economy on Wiz air I don't give
a
it's up to you stop calling me you know
the parameter you decide thank you so
where's your where's your private jet
I don't have a private jet
[Music]
but look I know we didn't work out this
time let me know if you ever want to do
it again in the future and well we
didn't you know not to film an interview
obviously we we have the phone calls
that we had outside your house and I
guess we can use those unless you've got
an issue with that yeah I do have I do
have an issue I haven't signed a consent
form
[Laughter]
okay well
in that case
um
I guess
let me know if you change your mind at
any point maybe in may like your lawyer
said we can do another thing
perhaps damn he didn't give him the
chocolate we guessed wrong
yeah put it all in the chat put a one in
the chat if you thought he was gonna get
the chocolate put it too in the chat if
you didn't
damn that's a bit he's a bit stinky you
know
two pound
absolutely yeah I didn't try to consent
form and it's a shame the BBC with their
big budgets made you fly economy wizard
that must be very annoying for you to
fly in and out for no reason I feel
sorry for you man
the struggle out here you'll survive
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
what
I can't read it can you read it what
does it say is it uh you said it must be
weird having a bus and that was it is
sadly I'm driving away now call me when
you are next free
it was him holding the chocolate in the
plane and the uh it is a broken life
should enjoying the War Room
[Laughter]
you know
yo take investors it's funny it was so
funny guys
[Music]
that's the bankruptcy
yeah
oh wouldn't be wouldn't it be funny if
Tate buys Vice oh that would be so funny
oh Mr T that's the chest move you've
been waving oh
yeah how crazy it is it to be valued at
5.7 billion and then to go to nothing
yeah that can happen when you do hit
pieces on people you know
yeah because here's the thing like
people know what's true and what's not
true and they might not immediately but
when people do bad faith reactions when
people do bad faith Clips they might not
figure it out right away but in the long
run the test of time shows character it
shows what people are about and the
people aren't stupid they start to see
through it they start to see
and the truth of the matter is a bunch
of these reaction channels and news
places don't care about the truth they
don't care about what's right and the
only thing they care about is making
their money and getting their coin and
criticizing everyone along the way and
they just sit there on hours and hours
and hours of you talking waiting for
something that they can take out of
context
but here
I'll adjust pearly things Network
we believe in freedom of speech yes sir
we believe let's go we believe in
freedom of speech we believe in giving a
platform to those who have been
de-platformed and we believe
and stopping all this goddamn
from these reactions I'm so tired of
these people calling this man these
reaction channels have been saying that
Tate committed a crime that he didn't
commit
if that can happen to the average man or
sorry if that could happen to a man with
money power and Status what happens to
the average guy
there's no chance Tate could fight these
accusations but the guy next door he
can't do
yeah
let's see how this ends yeah
oh take care
I was at the end
the war room is the greatest Global
Network which exists on planet Earth the
war room is a global organization
because some of these Super Shots you
know I mean I'm going to read them out
yeah yeah we gotta read them out you
know
thank you many Delgado
24 MX I don't know what that is but
onset
uh thank you Amina pelsi's full of
energy God bless you keep it up
it's for you there pal thank you Tony
Oliver
4.99 could be five dollars
can you comment on what role chat GPT
has with Fox News
CNN BuzzFeed I think you read this one
already
told Tosh I do not say your mate your
name mate but it's two dollars
uh I'm not gonna really supercharge and
it's
30.99 I'm not a broker yeah Nicholas
thank you radio super trust Adam thank
you
Jerome thank you for the memberships
Levi thank you hahaha
macros thank you chat is spending all
his money on weed
Stacy thank you
seeking Eden thank you every redhead
girl I've ever met has smoked pot just
saying okay well I'm not one of them
stop it I don't know what's going on I'm
not
oh I don't know I don't do drug you know
I don't do drugs I don't know what
they're seeing you know I mean
uh okay I think that's the end okay you
know that's the reason I'm super shots
you know uh I want to see did he post
anything else on Twitter uh we're gonna
go there milk Ringo love the content
20 or 1999 but almost twenty dollars
thank you
uh this is for early morning stream get
some rest two dollars muscle grow saying
thank you
oh it's next year ten dollars to monster
91.
tell I got some oranges cigars chocolate
some history and to make the deal better
I'll make some home bread homemade bread
if you don't have to bake I guess that's
what they're saying here wait what
someone said you have to make some uh
homemade bread for hell with hate
I can make homemade bread for tea yeah
who who said that that's
tea monster 91.
10 okay yeah what we gotta do to get him
here you just don't yeah I can't promise
it'll be good homemade bread but I'll do
the best I can you try you know you know
what I mean we're Danes Daisy man
dollars 99
Zachary Lewis 1999
we all knew this was coming your cape of
the good way this was no clickbait guys
it was his first interview anyways and
we wanted to come here you know yeah
what are you
yeah now they're doing false accusations
against my producer of Click baiting
same with clickbait a false accusation
come on man you guys enjoyed that
interview you know you're coming to say
you know you saw that was funny
you know 4.20 for the Brookie pearly
thing Clementine and Jet fund apparently
we have a jet fund I didn't I don't even
know that was happening but
uh chocolate for blessing Stacy Campbell
14.9 thank you thank you I want to die
right now though but thank you
Ron uh quack run 25 hello from Romania 3
30 a.m here and I can't sleep
if you want to escape the matrix Romania
is not the place for you yeah clearly we
can see that
it is actually Tuesday here in the UK
uh two dollars you will never you are
never on my page but I subscribed plus
Bell sauce yeah I've been YouTube is
Shadow burning us guys so please just
keep checking our Channel we are live
almost every night you get time
stuck in the system five dollars first
and foremost
FTS this is play play and Foolery
respectfully
oh well that's that's what we do here
where is Destiny to apologize to top G
yeah I I would like to facilitate an
apology between Destiny and Tate
you know Destiny since you feel so bad
about all the accusations you know
I am going to be so helpful
and helping you
facilitate an apology to Tate
where you say you were wrong yeah
he's not gonna do it Sam and then
you Heisenberg 1.99 please reveal the
certified body for whatever we will do
that
King kamate hell can you make a tour
girl crew I'm 5 11 also from New York
yes I can all right all right no I'm not
Heist leave it alone in the chat I'm
just tired it's late as hell it is 2 30
in the morning in the UK guys after a
show it's a bit bad uh Prodigy 4.99 we
need that SpongeBob clip of that one do
screaming chocolate yeah
you inspire me to be a good wife thank
you making wife is out there
Marco uh question uh Pfizer chocolates
yeah
it might be something like that you know
I'm saying Mike Tyler Perry would you
let uh nope ignore that one okay now
back Tyler you almost got me dead no no
no no no
they always give you these questions so
it's like
you realize halfway you know I'll be
like oops
it's fun now all right oh we want to go
on Twitter yeah I want to go on Twitter
let's see what he's posted on Twitter oh
no no should we no I'm looking at my
phone
he said so oh it's just about the vice
is the last thing he tweeted
um guys guys what should what should my
pitch be to Tate should we do it yeah
all right yeah guys uh yeah actually
whoever brings the biggest super trust
gets to tell us yeah
of course I know I say your name brother
I see you
let's see
help us out guys help us yeah but I say
stop begging for supers sorry look at
they're broke it's fine just let them be
broken listen man I have faith in my
guys you know all right I'm thinking I'm
thinking
[Music]
um
guys we are watching live is pale sends
a message to Tay
of history and we'll bring clementines
chocolates
I don't know a better pitch than that
damn golden Khalil 99 come on man we
don't have brookies I told you I have
faith in my people oh wow wow I'm saying
golden
I have faith in my Valentines and
chocolate yeah
wow
should I send that
you think we're seriously
oh yeah you're right we're super serious
beautiful people yeah
foreign
then you're getting offered tape value
and yay value by getting chilled out by
Tate
these are like two people that we read
wait can you grab my phone from my room
okay I'll I'll call I'll call I'll call
Nick I'll see I'll see if he's down
oh on life let's do it yeah
yeah
well I just I don't see why not
he's running he's running guys
you'd watch that you see
Pearl are you a gold digger what the no
well maybe a little bit I mean guys
let's just call spade a spade you know
you don't want no women want to date a
guy that's completely broke so you know
I think smart women gold dig a little
bit but for the right values they gotta
have the values with it it can't just be
money
okay wait so
so I should pitch this to to Nick
um
all right
um what time is it in the US is this
super late no I I think it should be
I don't think so it's Tuesday here
okay
guys they take interview is coming I'm
15.
okay
let's see let's see
he's a busy guy well
okay never mind you didn't answer
um I tried I tried my best
oh someone put it here all right dear
Andrew Matt may have a history with you
but we have clementines let us know if
we if we can visit you oh that's a good
one that's a good one yeah and he put He
put that's an extra 19 after he pulled
99 you know golden Khalil yeah I like
that one he's a serious guy here and I
mean
golden you just sent a DM to Enrique
congratulations congrats
500.
[Laughter]
or never
someone should send the stream to Matt
what
is this someone should send this stream
to Matt
oh that Matt yeah okay yeah see I
already forgot his name that's how
irrelevant he is
I just typed it you know what I mean
you know
yeah
Pearl do you have an opinion on Roma
Army I do have an opinion on Roma Army
um she dmed me a while ago she dmed me a
while ago asking
to come on the show and I was down to be
honest I just get so many messages and I
don't know where I got lost or along the
way because this girl tagged me in his
community post and was like oh I know
why Pearl blocked me and I saw the tag
and I was like
I didn't block you
so I don't know where that came from
that's my only opinion my only opinion
was I was like why was I
anyways yeah if tayden yeah run for
elections that's going to be a tad one
tayden yay run for election yeah on the
bid
oh my gosh Tate for president that would
be
to be honest it taken Year campaign is
there just a win oh Nick Nick called
back
wait
hey hello
how are you
I'm good I'm on a stream
mine I do YouTube you know
oh well I didn't know
on someone else's stream no no no no
they're saying in the chat that we
should
um Pitch a video with like me you
um
Tate and yay
I don't think yeah you'll be up for it
but uh
I mean I'm down to do it with tape
you don't think yay would do it
I mean I'll run it by him but
buddy Loki these days okay I want to get
everyone that's been canceled on a panel
I think I would like break the internet
yeah I think that'd be fire and uh
Tate's out of jail right so yeah
has um
has freaking have Trump and yay squashed
beef
uh no not to my knowledge but uh yay did
squash the beef with these lines so oh
that's good yeah lit but Elon is
actually canceled is he that can you
come back on Twitter
well there's been discussion about that
but okay I don't want to get you in
trouble
okay
um well let me let me know I I think it
would break the internet I think it'd be
crazy
yeah
I'm open to it of course I don't know I
don't know if Tate would want to be on a
stream with me though I'm a little uh
a more controversial than you so no way
what do you mean what controversy
a little bit
um okay
I I feel like I feel like he's gonna say
yes oh the chat's saying hi to you
hi we miss you out we miss you out here
you know
blessings blessings still
yeah yeah don't stop stop
don't do this to me
flossing's still traumatized he's still
super traumatized you know
yeah
I miss him I miss him
okay we need to bring me chocolates yeah
would you bring him chocolates next time
we're coming to Chicago
um I think in like
end of the month yeah end of the month
if you're there
yeah I think I'll be here let me know
and we can uh collab or hang out or
something okay okay
um let me know what yay says
yeah I'll run it by him I I I I feel
like this this would break the internet
okay
okay well thanks Nick
all right I'll tell you the chat misses
you
okay
okay bye
you know exclusive guys
all right all right we will try that
foreign we'll try that
um Trump and Tate if you can do that
it'd be better than Tate look here I'm
open to everybody
Trump and Tate oh damn
yay man I want everybody with that party
you love it
yeah
I think whoever's Channel that's going
to be on there to make some uh
reservations that they are now
considering themselves canceled you know
what if you put taeye and uh trample on
the panel yeah
just know that you're a cancer from
there now you can't have a bank account
just move all your money to bitcoin you
know I'm saying
all right
I sent it
uh that was a win chart thank you yeah
I'm really glad we went through this
together
you know this is what women do when we
text men just so you know like behind
the scenes this is like you guys don't
even know there's like you'll be like Oh
I'm just texting with my girl oh no it's
like a perfectly constructed text that
like five women have put together
if we like you anywhere
yeah
you know Alex Jones Kanye Tate and Trump
damn I'm for it
yeah
yeah this one yeah
yeah I want to do this one live at the
O2
live at the O2 yeah
yeah we could do it
I feel like the podcast game is like the
new music game you know I'm saying that
we should be doing podcast toes uh but
we got brookies so
yeah
a lot of
a lot of brokies
all right
I'm so tired the chat's kind of I kind
of miss doing these live chats I should
stream more today you know they're so
active
thank you
Yo Taco Carlson as well you know and
don't let me know the panel how can we
make that happen yeah oh I'll send it to
Tristan too
I mean let me message Tristan I don't
have his number but he follows me on
Twitter
yeah guys at some point I think just
barely things might be canceled you know
follow us on Rumble
yeah I have a question guys do you think
I kind of miss doing reaction lives but
I don't know
is
sometimes I want to go back to reacting
more
but I'll leave so much time and I'm up
to three shows a week I don't know guys
what do you think blessing
I think we should just get more
educational content on them yeah
one-on-ones when we're in America yeah
we might a lot of one-on-ones in America
yellow 101s in America yeah
a lot of PODS but let me know what you
guys think in the comments you know I
actually want to run into that should I
start a tech Channel
yes I've been telling you to start a
tech Channel
I'm gonna have to show my face
you can just do it without your face
yeah
anyways Tech Channel coming up
and
um and blessings been doing good he went
to the trainer today
yeah that was you know that was that
wasn't bad actually oh shoot we have to
go to three four five six seven eight
nine ten I wish to get up in seven hours
we gotta go to bed
damn it man I got so many things to do I
think the dating show I'm gonna schedule
tomorrow
yeah yeah okay actually a couple
announcements let's go through some
announcements for the channel yeah let's
go this is nothing to do with Tate so if
you want the Tate content just go off
thank you bye goodbye thank you we we
sent we sent the message out you know
we'll see what he says
we understand either way
um
now further all the reaction channels
that came for me
the last two months
month
I just like to say
number one any requests to not have the
dating show put out is very selfish
because the employees that you're so
concerned about
they did not in fact are they they put
in their time their effort and all the
other content creators that came forward
so it's very selfish to ask us not to
post stuff because of your selfish needs
now because of that I don't care we will
be posting that this week
um request denied denied
um also guys blessing is still waiting
for your call
it for your concern about him
especially those of you that were in
studio
and didn't ask for his and didn't ask
some of you connected with him on
Instagram
that were in studio not going to name
names and never reached out to him
same with Auntie
and some of my other talents so you know
we'd also we're also going to be doing
um
a very interesting video coming up about
the unfair journalism in the space
yeah
and really giving some examples of where
journalism has gone awry
and I'm really excited to put that video
out God only knows because you know
blessing is very you know
slow sometimes you know he's a
perfectionist so it's got to be perfect
but it's fine you know he is the best he
has top producer he's the best producer
in the game so it'll be coming out but
the
yeah we're excited to release all dating
show episodes
yeah I was gonna give them a sneak
preview but I was like I'll give it to
him let's show him
preview guys all right exclusive I'm
gonna give them the trailer though
and we just yeah let me get the trailer
ready
all right we're gonna we're gonna oh
wait someone said tape Fuentes and Gabby
it
all right guys let put a one in the chat
if we should release the dating show
that we were asked not to release by
selfish content creators
put a one in the chat put a one in the
chat oh let me play Let me let me give
them a preview man yeah actually let me
just show you guys a preview
oh it's not on the screen
okay okay yeah but wait hold on put a
what I just want to make sure
um put a one in the chat if we should
release all dating show footage because
they care about the black content
creators that were involved in the
footage don't they yeah they wouldn't be
so selfish damn it wasn't a lot of one
yeah they wouldn't be so selfish to not
want to release that footage that the
staff that they were so con so concerned
about
worked so hard on blessing did you
receive a call and
tell them about your trauma
listen I've you know gained weight
just stressing and stressing that's why
I'm in the gym you know
traumatized daily
you know keep the ones coming keep the
ones coming you know now did anyone so
all those job offers that were offered
to my staff did anyone take those
what's to work for them green screen
people in there yeah yeah because
they're hard
like come work for me bro if you're you
are somewhere in America how am I even
gonna get there you know but people tell
them what you thought of their
production quality
a lot of people need help out there
that's why I'm starting a tech Channel I
just want to help you guys yeah blessing
it doesn't do charity he doesn't
you know we we pay well at jpt we don't
oh yes indeed yeah like we don't he
doesn't you're not going to these
charity channels this isn't charity work
yeah I already listen before pal I'll
work for a lot of people
I'll say like myself you know I'm not
gonna go into details about what that
means but what I was saying I worked
with a lot of people like those that
offered me jobs you know and I know how
you normally how people like that
function not saying names
but anyways they can afford me that's
what I'm gonna say yeah yeah I mean we
could see by their production quality
they certainly can't afford you yeah
yeah yeah um and I know anyways so are
we getting ones in the chat there's
little ones and they're ready for the
trailer they're ready playing the thing
play the thing no no I mean I just lost
I'm having so much fun let's let's just
go through the pros and the cons so the
pros of releasing the footage would be
my team didn't waste their time
just amazing you know the the content
the money we would make off this content
would go towards supporting my amazing
producer that they were so worried about
build the best studio on YouTube yes
um yeah so that's that's what the the
YouTube Revenue would go towards um and
it would give exposure to all of the
black content creators that worked so
incredibly hard to be a part of this
footage
yeah
um
um or we could
not release it and waste everyone's time
and care about a certain someone I won't
name names
feeling
first who made a hit piece on me hmm
without watching the full footage which
he admitted to
won't name names if I what if I had to
no names no names
you know
um trailer is coming and put misleading
captioning
on thumbnails saying I said words I did
not say
we could worry about that person's
feelings
or we could just release the footage but
let's let's watch the footage and decide
as a team let's find out what's going on
in this feeling yeah let us know if this
show is worth every
we're gonna do it anyways what's the
last meal that you cooked oh I like this
one um a salmon and asparagus
she's good
I got the shot okay how does that make
you feel
damn it where's the Poke listen y'all
that I do need what's up with Munich
where's Pearl at
hey how are you Krista
away
I don't know what the what was that who
are y'all bringing them in for me stop
producer will y'all bringing them in
with me what was that what was that what
was that
hey man can I get a hug
[Music]
you don't want to waste that footage
would you yeah
the red pill Bachelor coming you
wouldn't want to waste that footage the
red pill Bachelor coming soon
and bachelorette actually yeah and yeah
coming coming soon
yeah
um so what do you guys think one in the
chat
one in the chat if we should release it
two in the chat if we should just
someone says that the dude one not yes
that's the dude this one not yep
I forgot about that
um
why would you do that stop why would you
guys do that
one in the chat one in the chat
um oh damn okay okay you guys want it
out yeah
all right all right damn cha
um hello ones out there
couple twos but you know misleading
[Music]
okay
yeah
and should we talk about all the
misleading footage
do you think we should talk about all of
the misleading should I give my side of
the story
foreign
why would you guys do that why would you
guys do that
uh won that bachelor in the chat
does that look exciting can we show them
a little bit of another clip
uh do we have any of the amiri's clip
that he did with Melanie do you have it
none of them
watch the real stuff is it's not oh yeah
it's just okay can you this they want
another trailer they want another one no
it's like we could just show them a
little more
there's never enough
fine fine
blessing's a party pooper
yeah one more episode
just show them
[Music]
up
so you don't care about marriage
I'd also like to say we don't negotiate
with terrorists here
that's all
yeah
real people Bachelor coming to you guys
you know soon Brad pill Bachelor yeah
God only knows
but soon yeah you know
I do I would like to say thank you to
all of um
to my hard-working
uh
amazing what did you think I was gonna
say
what do you think what would you what
would you think I was gonna do today
would you would you would you
what'd you think I was gonna
try to rile up this reaction Channel
yeah yeah yeah but then give them
content
is
anyways
um
so
thank you guys for watching you know
sorry I was wild and a little bit on
live today you know but like the video
on your way out all right
yeah guys please do support the channel
uh yeah thank you for your contributions
as well
yeah thank you guys I know we don't have
a hundred percent bro and stop saying
about drugs I'm not on drugs I see your
comment I'm not I'm not on drugs all
right I'm just anyways like the video on
your way out guys subscribe to the
channel ring that notification Bell and
I'll talk to you next time